hola estamos aquí con ben él es nuestro
desarrollador de ejercicios experto así
que bienvenido bien cómo estás hola sale
muy bien dicho muy bien mira vamos a ver
este módulo que nos hiciste ir sobre
divisibilidad verdad perfecto sí sí ok
nos preguntan cuáles son los factores de
7 y veo que tengo una una especie de
cajita en la cual veo que tengo 7 puntos
y cuál es la idea en este la idea es
cambiar las dimensiones de la del
rectángulo exacto mira en este
rectángulo tienes un borde aquí hasta el
final el cual podemos ir moviendo y va a
cambiar
la cantidad de filas graves de neumours
ya veo pero si te das cuenta seguimos
teniendo los 7 mismos puntos lo único
que está cambiando es la cantidad de
filas que nosotros tenemos esas regiones
y filas y los miles de filas y columnas
o reynolds lo podríamos pensar clark muy
bien o si se ve a todo dar entonces
saber por ejemplo me preguntan los
factores de 7 pero en este caso creo que
pues bueno hasta donde yo entiendo
tenemos un número primo vamos a jugar
con el módulo pero se me hace que no
vamos a tener muchas posibilidades de
ver pero tú qué piensas velar o salteras
la razón el siete es un número primo y
por lo tanto podemos ver en un principio
que 71 son factores decir aclaró es la
definición del primo esto es algo muy
bien entonces
tú dices que si el 7 y el 1 son factores
los escribo de este lado estévez exacto
creo que sí oye bueno espero que lo
mismo seguridad tú lo hiciste oye se
importa el orden no importa el orden
pero es importante poner todos los
pactos al 500 aquí pongo al 1 te parece
y luego el 7 me pagará hubiera dado lo
mismo que pusieron yo primero el 7 y
luego en un exacto sales actual es
padrísimo entonces yo lo que te propongo
vamos a ir viendo este qué pasa si es
que 7 tiene otros factores entonces por
ejemplo el 2 y el 6 pues no verdad no
dividen ni el 6 nietos no divide
especialmente 2 no divide de manera
exacta al 7
claro que estamos haciendo está
trabajando con enteros estás de acuerdo
bueno entonces no pues el 5 y el 2 se ve
que tampoco luego vamos a ver todas las
posibilidades el 4 y el 2 pues tampoco
funciona
tampoco funciona el 2 y el 4 no tenemos
la misma cantidad de puntos a hacer este
pero y regresamos otra vez a 16 acá lo
que teníamos tenemos decir efectivamente
qué te parece si comprobamos nuestra
respuesta me parece perfecta ideas vamos
a ver qué pasa eso vamos a hacer el
siguiente no porque éste nos tocó un
caso muy especial de un número primo a
ver vamos a ver la diferencia ahora mira
ahora está más interesante este porque
ahora se trata de trabajar con el 8 que
mira a mí se me antoja un poco porque lo
veo a 8 s es para entonces ya ven nos
encontraremos cosas interesantes se
manda a pelear por ahí nos encontramos a
ver qué te parece si de una vez ponemos
el 8 y el 1 y el 8 el hielo no se tiene
razón tele 8 y 12 son factores muy bien
perfecto y entonces ahora ver vamos
viendo el módulo entonces pues no 7 y 2
pues como que no funcionan o no pero 7 y
22 claro 7 y 2 no son este sumó su
producto no da 8 exactamente claro
además no tenemos la misma cantidad de
puntos entonces el 6 y 2 son los que
tampoco funciona a ver vamos viendo el 5
y el 2 juego con zion de lujos y muy
bien claro porque 4 por 28 exactamente
serían los mismos puntos en las dos
filas perfecto entonces voy a poner el 4
y el 2 exactamente hoy ven pero y si ya
por otro digamos si hubiéramos
registrado el 4 y el 2 lo tengo que
repetir o nada más lo dejo una vez no es
muy importante solamente ponerle una vez
para que así tengas la respuesta
correcta a perfecto eso muy bien saberlo
entonces a ver continuemos este punto
que encontramos más estévez a ver
llegaron tres pues no mira otra vez
tenemos el 12 exactamente pero ya lo
pusimos entonces el último regresamos a
8 y 1
y sí sí tiene sentido porque cuando sea
8 sus factores son 1 como todos los
números 4 y 2 porque todos por 4 son 8 y
hoy evans que es el mismo pero hace nada
perfecto acá tienes razón eso se me
estaba olvidando pero veamos eso
perfectamente continuamos bien hoy
en el módulo de la verdad ahora tenemos
nos preguntan los factores del 10 esto
se pone interesante ven muy bien
entonces
qué te parece como ya estábamos haciendo
en los otros ejercicios empezamos por el
10 y el 1 porque son factores de 10 me
parece excelente idea sal y así con
ganas de una vez
entonces el 10 y el 1
vamos a mover el borde a ver qué
encontramos muy bien entonces empecemos
pues 9 y 2 no funciona no se ve que no
se va llenando la fila de abajo pero
poco a poco el 6 y el 22 por 5 son steve
es 10 tienes toda la razón el 2005
dividen de manera exacta el 10 perfecto
sigamos el 4 y el 3 pues no funciona el
3 y el 4 tampoco tensión mira es decir
funciona pero ya lo tenemos puede ser
así el medio está es muy bien y
regresamos al 1 y el 10 efecto efecto
entonces ya tenemos todos los factores
de 10
vamos a comprobar nuestra respuesta
oye pues muchas gracias bien de nada sal
cuídate mucho y nos vemos luego hasta
luego